this underwater trove of colorful reefs
serve as refuge and habitat to some of
the most diverse marine species
on the planet australia's great barrier
reef boasts one-third of the world's
coral population
but it's under threat and so too is a
wildlife
that relies on it the eastern pacific
ocean
is heating up fast since the mid 90s
this has caused the death of
half of the reef and has led to u.n
officials recommending it to be placed
on a list of world heritage sites
considered
in danger but the australian government
isn't happy about it countries including
european countries have got strong views
about what policies different countries
should have on climate change
and i understand that as well but this
is not the convention in which to have
those conversations
last year the reef recorded its highest
sea surface temperature
since records began in 1900
when the ocean heats up corals expel
algae
that causes them to bleach only the most
resilient
survive unesco has called for the in
danger listing
to be adopted at its next world heritage
committee meeting
but it's the second time that it's tried
to add it to the list
six years ago the australian government
lobbied the 21 country committee
to drop the listing it said unesco
didn't consider the billions of dollars
it contributed towards the reef's
protection
but some experts say australia is
resisting a commitment to the net
zero carbon emissions level by 2050.
and that its over reliance on fossil
fuels may be contributing to climate
change
that means making very definite
decisions on climate change
not heading towards supporting the
fossil fuel industry in this country and
opening new coal mines
new gas developments none of those
things are going to help climate change
but also taking as much action as we
possibly can
on improving water quality for the great
barrier reef
three thousand separate reefs and nine
hundred islands
make up the great barrier reef but
with fifty percent of the reef already
gone many
question whether unesco's move will make
much difference
laura berdiman the al jazeera